Our Lives going to be at risk so what
we've got in place with NHS England is a
system where they can flag to us four
times a day if there are any concerns at
all right so they can talk to us and we
have the system up in place and the
72-hour strikes where they were able to
communicate with us and not a single
safety concern was race so we have this
safety net but we know that our
colleagues our senior SAS doctors and
Consultants these are the expert
clinicians can safely provide care okay
so what happens if they say yeah we do
need the doctors what happens then so
there's a system in place where where
NHS England can communicate with us the
BMA will assess the risk and find places
where they can staff hospitals
adequately so what challenges might
these hospitals have to be in before
your doctors will go back to work so the
framework is all available to all NHS
trusts so they can assess self-assess
and refer themselves to the NHS England
NHS England will then review the risk
give of them options as to how they can
safely staff their units with their
existing staff and if this isn't
possible they'll contact the BMA and
have discussions with us about what we
need to do so in your opinion lives are
not at risk as a result of this strike
no so we were able to do the 72-hour
strike safely and that demonstrates that
we do have expert clinicians who can
safely step down and we do have enough
doctors to carve the wards if this
changes or if there is a mass casualty
event we urge every trust to contact us
because patient safety is first and
foremost okay at 35 is what you want
so what we're asking for is pay
restoration now that means that we need
35 which is 35 yeah I'm gonna get it so
what we're asking for is five to ten
pounds per hour more for every single
doctor now what we're seeing in the NHS
at the moment we need to look at this
through the state that the NHS is in at
the moment we've got 7.2 million
patients on waiting lists this is more
than we have people living in Scotland
we aren't operating the government isn't
operating uh Health Service they're
operating a waiting list and we've got
500 patients dying needlessly every week
we can't solve this without doctors 7.2
million yeah and you're adding another
350 000 over the next four days so there
will be patients that have their
appointments and operations canceled the
reason for this is because the
government won't negotiate with us they
haven't given us an opening offer and
without an opening offer there's nothing
to negotiate so you'd settle for less
than 35 percent we'll settle to find a
way in which we can get payroll
this is ultimately so just to clarify
doctor forgive me you say pace
restoration is 35
are you saying that you would negotiate
on that or not because you won't pay
restoration which is 35 so is that a
starting point or is that
um if you don't get that you're just
going to go out on strike again and
again so that is our opening offer we're
open to creative ways in how we can
restore the pay otherwise you know
doctors but we need to appreciate that
we are 9 000 doctors now and with
Millions on the waiting list we can't
bring this that number down without
doctors and patients know this is what
patients are appreciating that the the
reason they can't see their GP the
reason they can't see a hospital
specialist is because they want any and
public do support us
doctor not a vocation
it is a vacation but of course if we've
got to the point where the workforce is
in crisis when we can't give the level
of care that we want to give patients
and doctors are leaving to go Australia
New Zealand or Canada we need to do
something about this this is ultimately
so we can provide the care that we want
to
it's it's
Junior doctors I mean the Clue's in the
title I mean nobody would think that
doctors don't earn a good salary as they
climb up the ladder to the extent where
Consultants are only coming back to work
because they're being told at the cap of
more than a million pounds on their
pension can be lifted
so Consultants have seen a huge uh
decrease in their pay
um they've seen a pay erosion higher
than Junior doctors have and is the
highest in the public sector they've
lost 35 of their pay a million pounds in
the in the pension pots so that's I mean
the world's smallest uh fiddle from my
viewers at home who were struggling to
put money in the electric meter so
that's a hypothetical Port of money that
is growing with inflation like our wages
should and we can't speculate on what's
going to happen in the future and people
need to pay for their energy bills they
need to pay for their food and
Essentials right now
um you are confident that nobody's life
will be put in danger as a result of
this strike action how confident can you
be of that because I've been speaking to
obviously the other side of the argument
they'll have a different view I
understand that but they are saying uh
they they can't guarantee that
so I can't guarantee that no lives will
be put over this but what I can
guarantee is that 500 patients are dying
waiting for Care at the moment in
December alone we saw 50 000 patients
waiting longer than 12 hours in accident
and emergency so essential care that
they needed they waited over 12 hours
for 50 000 of them
you can't guarantee that no lives are at
risk what I can guarantee is that
emergency care essential care will be
provided by expert clinicians in
hospitals so these are the experts that
you see in clinics that make you
understand but you just said that you
can't guarantee that no lives will be
put at risk as a result of strike action
but you also said that doctors it's a
vocation to be a doctor
so what I'm saying is that no I can't
guarantee that no license will put a
risk this week but that's because their
lives are being put at risk every single
week at the moment we've got the expert
doctors in hospitals so these are
doctors that may not usually be at
hospitals we only have juniors in and
they are looking after the patients they
can provide care better care than we can
I'm guessing that you're going to blame
the health secretary
um for the situation that you find
yourselves in and why not what would you
say to him this morning what 50 000
Junior doctors out on strike today
they're all asking for pay restoration
so we can fix this Workforce crisis I
can only hope that he'll listen